you
get your king in the center and that's
just like checkmate so
strategy don't be so quick to castle and
also removing your opponents enter pawns
I find a good good idea get rid of them
grab some space as well so I'm looking
to push that night around space invaders
okay so maybe King here oh the bishop
has something to say about that that's
capture
and do what next okay I'm gonna play
here I want to get rid of it early there
LightSquared Bishop I just take take
here on a recap
let's take here first they have a
structural defect on e3
Queen takes and then King e7 I think
this is a nice hum hmm let's capture I'm
gonna
inside castle king here's a good move I
think I should have captured they would
have gone on castled if the Queen's are
off my king is really really quick to
get towards the center less than 2014
white I'm going to take that
hit hit them with the fork and why not
she definitely go for that on takes
night
in ten seconds
let's take that I'm on the other night
you take their palm
check let's do that and play here no
matter what and the game's not even
gonna end I should have played here but
ok let's give a check take with the pond
just so the King doesn't approach back
to tournament they're down on time whoa
a lot of games finished before mine I'm
in 27th place okay I like the
Scandinavian that 4-4-2 gambits gamuts
to eliminate those center pawns
ah let's get my bishop out Knight f6
King e7 inch my way up is it too crazy
to do that already let's pin the knight
first King e7 I'm gonna go up and not
take the knight hanging out of my Bishop
King 2 here is putting a restriction on
that c3 Knight let's get rid of the
knight actually I'm already threatening
to take the knight and then
hmm let's go here I'm already
threatening mate and one pawn push is it
needed let me secure my king position I
can already make moves like Queen here
pawn takes Queen King takes let's do
this attack the knight I'm also if the
knight moves I have King here game over
I'm threatening King here game over I
have this square covered Bishop here I
have Queen check I think I won Queen
check take here and then I'm ready to
win again pawn pushes needed I take here
this is gonna be mate here I take with
check take and then King here is
unavoidable after he capture and I could
Preem of this okay that's game over back
to tournament 15th for for a lot of
fours not on the front page yet I have
to get to the front page there's a lot
of a lot of players in this one so JM
sand well let's stick with the
Scandinavian
okay they're not they're not so quick to
give up their pawn in the center so
that's gonna make it more like a regular
chess game let's keep the pin and let's
break the pin over here Queen c7 yeah
not so quick to Castle okay let's get in
b5 I think this is gonna just stay
around regular chess game you're really
gonna take that okay we're gonna go for
an attack right there okay this is with
check let's pre move this I'm turning
mate game over game over stuff I'm
threatening okay this is this is a good
spot for my king relatively safe all
right let's look to kick their night
away they're doing similar with my
knight in the center they can take my
bishop woo they might hit me with a fork
here but we're gonna see okay this night
I believe just has to go no let's go
here f5 was getting a pretty serious now
let's remove this guy I want to trade
Queens can we make that happen
this knight needs to go there King is
way off from the center let's take here
Queen trade I think this is probably a
forced win if the Queen's are off yeah
my king is just way too close
he's way way off okay yeah so King here
and I'll be game over threatening mate
threatening to take the pawn and then
give me can't take this guy oh I think
I'm losing I got to do some bad things
they're gonna get in the center
ah oh they didn't get in the center why
didnt they play King here they lost on
time I thought they were just kind of
waiting you know like I'll wait to the
last point one seconds to you know
and this one Wow I I said that their
King was really far off from the center
but he moved really really fast he got
to the center real quick I gave up too
much material my my rook move I that I
should have had something other than
that
rook milf ha ha April one move away from
game ending tactics game hunting tactics
game ending moves a one move kill didn't
have time to pull the trigger on that
when I guess ok and another dark square
bishop so maybe it's a bit more likely
that I could get into a dark square in
the center mm-hmm
threatening a fork they could give a
check here
I don't know how scary that is I have to
square covered there in a pin huh
I have to watch out for their king oh
that's a wrong move I have to cover this
square can't let them get here they're
trying to kick me away stop it oh I have
this Knight check which is close to mate
I should have done this sooner
oh that's a freebie let's take him Queen
here um let's take here huh I just lost
no take my Oh No
all they had to take here and then King
here game over this is such a delicate
game such a delicate variant I'm playing
very bad and I'm just dodging a ton of
bullets that's that's all that's going
on right here like a prequel that game
over
back to tournament less than 22 oh man
wow I thought oh yeah this one's in the
bag I could do whatever Knight takes
bishop removes my Bishop from defending
e4 and then king e4 because Knight takes
bishop was with check and why am I
playing the nimzo-indian all of a sudden
I I'm forgetting it's king of the hill
okay I was ready to say less than a
minute remaining really that's what you
signed up for man you signed up the for
a one-minute tournament didn't you okay
ah this has to be good for me now I
could I could get my King in the center
right what piece would I really like to
get rid of I don't know I'll probably
this pawn let me get rid of him now
let's get rid of that Knight I want to
get to this dark square give me this
dark square would you would you please
let's go here 34 seconds I'm looking to
maybe even sack my bishop hmm
little bit too close for comfort here I
don't like it get away King get away
you're way too close
way too close okay I'm looking to just
give a check force the king a little bit
more away pawn push game over back to
tournaments so tempting those checks
so tempting I had a I had a strong
feeling it was it was only a strong
feeling for like a half a second but I
thought that might happen
it's a pawn push it's with check you
know what that was uh I was a game loser
right there king of the hill strikes the
Queen is out and about let's keep her
around clearly and let's throw a pin
right back is it too crazy to castle no
Castle queenside is probably good hmm
okay let's
a little bit scared there King gonna do
something dangerous
let's take here I'm gonna take this pawn
with the Queen I can't be right
let's break pins 32 seconds they have a
huge time lead huge alright let's see
what this Nets me anything good we're
gonna find out this this was not a good
move by me okay I think I had to do that
because they were threatening to take my
bishop with check I'm gonna take here
they are okay it's a giant giant race Oh
who's gonna win it I feel like I don't
even want to take that bishop I don't
care about you bishop threatening me
I don't want the bishop I want me let me
take I guess I'll take you now I have to
start covering some center squares I
think other King is way too close ah the
rooks gonna move with check oh I don't
have any time either
yeah that's game over King there ah back
to tournament oh I think I learned
something from that one that uh there
Ponte D for was a real pain OH
real pain I didn't like having to work
around that guy oh I gotta catch him
okay stay focused now stay focused I was
ready to castle don't you dare castles
so quick okay I got a catch I got a
catch-up there okay here we go
twenty twenty eighteen seventeen sixteen
let's run
gotta get some quick kills in here here
we go I am taking that guy I don't care
about my queen I don't care about the
Queen
take my queen I dare you I dare you to
take my queen I thought that that might
happen they're gonna win a piece but I
have my king really close to the center
so that's that counts for something
doesn't it let's do this
clear the way for this square Knight
takes Bishop I do that oh no I'm getting
flushed away this is this is not working
out so well okay
kamikaze style too early on I don't know
about that let's counter-attack against
the night I want to get back into
striking distance King here's where I
want to be take my rook close to the
center oh I'm getting flushed away again
they're doing a good job and their King
is gonna make a beeline right right
towards this square now oh I'm losing
the farm I'm getting mated forget about
trying to get the King towards the
center I'm just getting mated five
seconds as well
this guy's crunching me King get towards
the center my anyone oh yeah I'm really
gonna stop them from get in the center
where all my pieces I'm down in time as
well twenty to twenty to twenty I don't
have any firepower either I'm not on
streak twenty to twenty to twenty and
where am I at ninth place okay I have to
pick it up we're at the halfway point
that's back-to-back losses my king was
getting maybe a bit too crazy I think so
take it to crazy now with so many pieces
on the board I must say though the last
time I tried that those tactics going
towards the center real quick in the
early stage it was working out but not
this time around I insist though I
really do I think this is a fine move
come on King a little bit close not too
much just a hair
yeah okay I'll pull the trigger on that
one I gotta get out of the way
okay let's insert this check I guess
okay Queen block huh let's get rid of
that night okay I feel like I have much
better control now they can't get to the
center oh they're gonna pin me I'm
missing a ton of stuff Bishop here would
have been a killer
I'm not leaving letting this pawn move
interesting ending here for king of the
hill very interesting keep my pond right
here keep oh this is this is the idea
undermined this guy and then threatened
to get here at some point
I should be able to get this with my
knight I think he'll be able to work
some magic I'm relying on this night to
work some magic let's see if you could
pull it off I want to hang on to my hang
that's not a great way to do it he's now
boxed out but yeah this should be fine
I'm winning upon and eventually they
have to now move away from defense of
this square I'll get this one now
they're gonna run out of moves soon got
it back to tournament where am I at
second page 11th out of 97 who are now
in it 14 minutes remain collet let's see
how I get paired up with I need to get
back on streak here and some people have
to knock out okay this is the guy that
knocked me out one of the two have to
play maybe I should try regular chess
and not go to too crazy in the early
stage take my pawn to e4 this must be
good it must be good um let's do this
alright I'm gonna sneak this this has to
be good this is similar to what they did
against me now that's a little space
advantage guy right here he's tough to
work around King right up here right
here King is where you belong
alright mass exchanges
oh I got this I have to get this right
uh do I really have to I just gave them
a big center I could play my knight in
here I'll do it
they're gonna call a here with the
knight and cover the two Center squares
but I'm gonna try and chip away at their
center if they do that oh it's hanging
on to my pawn pawn push and scheme over
chip away at their pawns b3 b3 chip away
oh they're gonna win again now my king
is dangerous he's a dangerous dangerous
guy rook takes pawn if rook moves this
is killer
that's a matin - ha ha ha rook takes
pawn cannot be taken cannot take back
he's in a pin and then kingi forward
been game over back to tournament where
we have who is the leader gotta go back
to the front page 34 is top and I'm at
20 oh the other guy that beat me he's in
first Toth of sky RIT for less than 12
minutes remain all right let's open it
up mad dash towards the center I'll play
up by pawn here okay let's give a check
I like this that kind of Bishop moving
and running with the King up ah this
must be winning now Kingdom one of these
two you can't stop both let's game over
quick kill back to tournament thirty
thirty four thirty twenty four twenty
four I'm on streak I need to keep the
streak going here got a fight back he's
only slipped up once but it was early
these middle losses they're killers if
you're gonna lose a game you definitely
want to lose early on the first the
first game if you're are to have a loss
the first game is probably the the best
one to go for the best one to have that
happened okay what am I saying focus on
the game
gonna go with the castle alright let's
do this they're gonna play Knight here
or are they let's get rid of their night
and maybe their dark square Bishop King
e7 I could take that pawn at some point
okay like right now
but I feel like he's poison you know cuz
then that didn't that's another spoo I
could take here with check because
that's another square that that's then
available to the King be very careful I
have to keep these squares covered this
one keep this one covered let me go here
just to kick the King away a little bit
give a check okay sneak my queen in here
I shouldn't have allowed that there
really close oh I thought what they
would take with their king let's take
here and hmm their Knight is such a pain
okay this should be good though
just take here grab this rook and get my
King here pawn push next is dangerous
get out of there man ah their King is so
close oh my goodness I'll take you oh
I'll take take here and I'm threatening
mate get out of there King get out I
have it finally you need to get out of
here man check I'm gonna give a check
next and then get to e5 finally no II
five right here three seconds barely who
thirty four thirty two twenty eight
twenty eight that guy slipped up I'm on
streak neither of these two guys up top
are on streak I'm tied with someone else
who is on streak Anton cubed oh we all
know you have to watch out for Anton
squared
what does that say about Anton cubed is
he all the more dangerous
okay run King and run fast right here
that's game over I take the knight next
with check I'm threatening here that's
game over quick kill back to tournament
just like that 36 32 32 8 minutes remain
four points out from first I'm still on
streak there this is this is definitely
doable with those early speed bumps
corrupted okay let's try gambits let's
try gambits space advantage and having
no center pawns with your or I'll get
rid of getting rid of your opponent's
Center pawns two good things I think Oh
mad dash towards the center I'll take it
and hope for the best cover this square
these two are covered and get out of
there King and let's take here with
check not so fast
actually I feel like I could get my
opponent in mates
Oh No get out of there King Bishop here
no matter what pawn push stuff let me
get my King towards the center you could
take some material I want to get my King
towards the center a little bit I have a
bishop move with check I shot I probably
should have been looking into that soon
7 minutes remain hmm threatening me King
here that's tough to stop I got that
Bishop King here difficult to stop my
Queen could take out a bunch you know
anything that tries Queen h4 okay
keeping there that's me King to e4 back
to tournament who give me a second to
breathe that was a quick quick pairing
38 36 34 okay
still fighting still fighting overtake
this pond just like this a lot of
pressure on that guy and let's get her
app some more space I have a good
feeling about this one
King up here pond takes game over let's
throw another pond five pawns attack
okay uh I'll take twice No yeah I could
take here pawn takes Knight takes you
can't take back all right there's a lot
of tension in the center a real lot
attention let's get rid of their Queen
she's scaring me
let's take here first and then here pawn
takes Knight game over they might forget
hope chess if that's now hope chess I
don't know it is they might forget let's
give this check and then take towards
the center I guess okay they're running
away I like that very good to see
running away moves Knight here
interference tricks okay they eliminated
that Bishop here on Knight takes pawn
interference if their Knight moves
they're not they don't have any time uh
just anything they don't have any time
this game's not gonna finish here I
guess anywhere they're down on time back
to tournament 46 trying to say 42 46 40
I'm six points out six points is too
much do I have to start thinking about
going berserk with these last couple to
try and get a couple points
I might have to seriously consider that
let's go here King you two you gotta get
rid of that pond okay I'm coming up get
out of there king and queen okay
dangerous dangerous dangerous that's got
to be a poison pond right got to be take
with the night oh they're out of the pen
it's forgetting okay my rook is a
fighter my rook is a fighter I'm getting
this bishop get out of here man I'm
dropping this this might be okay this
might be some crazy advanced move let's
go here and then King here next stop me
from getting here I can grab that bishop
they got a playoff five they didn't play
a five they forgot back to tournament
just like that 50 44 this guy keeps
winning are we gonna have to pair it up
again six points out I gotta try it I'm
going berserk it's official and
especially berserk with probably a quick
crazy King move Queens off undermine
their center um okay I want to get rid
of their pawn King up here come on gotta
go fast they're gonna flush my king away
I'm gonna do it stay around King they're
gonna throw a pawn push in there yeah
they are okay
this really worked this was a brilliant
brilliant idea I'm getting mated I'm
gonna be mated almost almost Mike King
is a fighter he's definitely a fighter
he's a fighter King to d4 back to
tournament 50:49 two minutes left
232 29 to 28 Wow lucky lucky lucky
let's try bezerk again this is uh this
is a day
dangerous idea against a player like
this but you gotta try crazy crazy
things crazy things you take my night
okay
the pain train is coming here where did
that come from
watch out for Terry tape watch out for
Terry tape who knows about Terry Tate
let's kick that night away yeah
brilliant
okay pull the trigger on that one oh
there goes a queen free Queen Wow yeah
this really uh this was brilliant too
much too much is there any hope am I
just gonna get mated there any hope at
all any hope queens off there might be
hope get towards the center
five seconds there's no hope man there
Kings inching up can't stop that king
he's too strong way too strong oh just
like that game over oh and he slipped up
to wait is this that oh I have a chance
no I don't know I do
I went berserk so if I get this it'll be
a tie less than a minute why did I do
that
this game's not gonna finish this is the
leader this is the leader but he could
always do Nona Frey tactics you can
always do no - Frey tactics yeah let's
take care you take that building my
Center
go ahead I know you want to do it I know
you want to take my knight
give up your center post yeah it's not
gonna end it's not gonna end they could
always use Nonna fry tactics so in the
end I didn't have to go for that
I didn't have to go berserk hitting
their queen I want them to take my
knight nine seconds remain it's not
gonna work
yeah they're gonna call the tournament
14 seconds yeah that's it tournament
over they're not taking my night okay
okay now they're taking that maybe I
could still at least try to win here huh
let's give a check eleven seconds oh all
right well my king is cool I could block
here nine seconds let's go here I guess
my king is still way off getting to the
center isn't he ouch
I forgot about that move five seconds
okay Queen trade King here I don't know
what I'm doing let's check oh I want on
time oh but you won the tournament
ah nice real real close I felt the need
to go berserk probably the wrong idea in
hindsight but I think at the time it was
the right choice okay
final standings here total sky 52 52 42
let me scroll down a little bit here
they put Gigi's in that was tense good
games all nice final standings 52 scroll
just a little bit right there
52 49 44 44 40 and in the end it started
with 80 players so about 20 more mm-hmm
about 20 more entered during the
tournament 52 49 44 top three and here
where the rest of the players that took
part in this one who I don't know that
anybody got by without losing a game in
this one I have to check that front page
again but I think everybody ended up
with the goose egg and this one anybody
with perfect scores
everybody's vulnerable no squeaky-clean
performances are right Gigi's
you